hey guys it's Jenna here so I'm going to
take you in the gym and show you some of
the basic exercises which you can do
with a pair of dumbbells so I'm going to
show you the right techniques and go
into detail for each workout and also
things to avoid doing you can also do
these workouts at home if you're a
beginner and you want to start lifting
weights we should watch at this video
through let's start with our lower body
dumbbell squats which works on your
entire legs glutes hamstrings quads and
of the core so hold the dumbbells just
by your sides stand tall with your
shoulder width apart and pointing
straight ahead then lower your body and
squat as far down as you can you want to
make sure that your knees are at a 90
degree angle keep your chest up back
flat and look straight ahead don't let
your knees go over your toes and avoid
rounding your shoulders and back so push
your hips back and your body weight into
your heels your leg muscles are your
biggest muscles so you can choose
heavier weights between 5 to 8 kilos
each or more the next exercise is
alternate overhead lunge which also work
on your lower body and core but with the
addition of your shoulder muscles again
stand tall with your feet shoulder width
apart and pointing straight ahead hold
one dumbbell firmly overhead then take a
wide step forward with your right leg so
engage your core keep your chest up a
back straight and look ahead
so while maintaining this position bend
your legs to about a 90 degree angle and
lower your hips toward the floor the
back you should always be slightly
lifted your knees should not go past
your toes and avoid limbing your body or
unser forward or back then push your
body back up a 3 or front view and
return to starting position repeat an
alternate between each leg so for this
workout choose a dumbbell that weighs
between 5 to 8 kilos each let's move on
to our upper body bent over row which
works primarily on your back muscles and
also your biceps stand tall with your
feet shoulder width apart knees slightly
bent and pointing straight ahead bend
forward at your hips until your torso is
nearly parallel to the floor Hova
dumbbells crucifies with the palms
facing your body
and put the dumbbells up to with your
belly and squeeze your back muscles keep
elbows pointed back chest up and back
flat always keep the dumbbells close to
your sides avoid hinging your back or
using momentum to lift the waves grip
your back for a second or two right at
the top then lower to starting position
for your back muscles you can also use
between five to eight kilos each next
test press which works on your chest
muscles and also a little bit on your
shoulders and triceps so lie on the mat
with your feet firmly planted on the
floor keeping your knees bent hold the
dumbbells directly above your chest with
your elbows at a 90 degree angle
slightly lifted off the map
engage your chest muscles to push the
dumbbells up to word of the ceiling keep
the shoulders relaxed and dumbbells
should be directly at chest level the
dumbbells should not be a shoulder level
squeeze and hold for a second right at
the top and slowly lower the dumbbells
to starting position without resting
your arms on the map avoid letting the
dumbbells Fortier side okay always
control the movement now if your energy
you can also perform this workout on the
bench so for chest press start with four
to six kilos each the next workout is
bicep curl to show the press which will
work on your biceps shoulders and also
tricep muscles so hold pair of dumbbells
by a side with the palms facing forward
then clew your upper arms and bring the
dumbbells up to your shoulders always
keep your elbows close your torso
throughout the workout
avoid using momentum or move the entire
arms to lift the weights up there we'll
take a risk until your palms face
forward elbows out and away from your
body at about a ninety degree angle
engage your shoulders and press the
dumbbells up directly above your head
engage your core and keep your back flat
avoid arching your lower back or
overextending the shoulders behind your
head for about one count and reverse the
moves back to the starting position for
this workout choose something lighter
and not too light I'd say between three
to five kilos each next tricep kickbacks
to work on your chest muscles or the
bingo wings start on all fours
dumbbell in one hand with your upper
arms close clear total and parallel to
the floor there should be a 90 degree
angle between your upper arm and your
forearm so keep your back straight and
neck in a neutral position and gently
gaze at the floor as you exhale engage
the tracker muscles to lift the weight
until the arm is fully extended you
should only be moving the forearm the
upper arm should always remain in
position close to your total again avoid
using momentum Australian anti arm to
lift the dumbbell up always control the
movements and slowly bring the dumbbell
back to starting position complete
between two of the 15 repetitions on one
side and repeat on the other arm
now because your tricep muscles are
smaller muscles go for a lighter weight
between 2 to 4 kilos each now let's work
on a reverse fly which targets your
upper back and show the muscle hold the
dumbbells firmly at about shoulder level
with palms facing each other and elbows
slightly bent the ridge both arms
straight out to your sides until they're
in line with your body and squeeze your
upper back and shoulders for about 2
counts lower your arms in a controlled
manner and return to the starting
position avoid rounding your back or
collapsing your chest
always keep your back flat and chest
open your upper body should maintain as
still as possible with movements coming
only from your arms again these are
small muscles so go for lighter weights
between 2 to 3 kilos each let's end the
workout with some core exercises full
extension this exercise targets your
upper and also lower abs so whole one
dumbbell with both hands and lie on your
back with your arms extended overhead
and your legs extended out as you
breathe out curl up and bring your knees
to your chest and your arms towards your
ankle then take a deep breath in and
extend your legs and arms back to
starting position the movement should
always come from lifting your shoulders
of the storm keeping your neck of
somewhat relaxed and avoid arching your
lower back only bring your legs down as
far as you can while keeping a back
splash again control the movements to
keep your core tight and slowly lower
your legs down while resisting the force
of gravity for this workout choose
between 4 to 6 kilos
and the final word guard will be Russian
twist which works on the entire car and
also obliques so sit on the mat with a
nice band with one dumbbell in both
hands then keeping the spine long linked
back slightly until you feel your core
engaged twist the torso to the left and
immediately to the right in a continuous
motion look to it the direction you're
twisting to work on your car even more
you can lift your legs few inches of the
floor and find your balance remember
that the movement should be coming from
your torso rotating not just your arms
swinging in the left to the right and
avoid rounding your shoulders always
keep your back flat show this put back
and chest open you can use the same
weight after the core exercise before so
guys I hope you find this video to be
useful perform all nine exercises as a
total body strength training workout in
this sequence
I've laid out in about 45 minutes ok so
a to perform between chops to 15 reps
per exercise if you can lift more than
15 repetitions event of weights are too
light you need to increase the weight so
if you're an absolute beginner then aim
to complete 2 sets per workout before
moving on to the next exercise
as you progress then aim to complete
between 3 to 4 sets if you're looking to
buy dumbbells I would recommend buying
two pairs of dumbbells one heavy weight
between 5 to 6 kilos each and another
life of pair between 3 to 4 kilos each
it's always better to get heavier pair
of dumbbells because then you can train
and progress into lifting heavier don't
bother buying a really light pair of
dumbbells because then to be honest you
can just make your own using a pair of
bottle water ok so if you do have any
questions in regards to lifting weights
or working out with dumbbells do leave
them in the comments below and I'll try
my best to answer all of them to check
out more workout video links in the
description box below to get you through
your fitness journey and you can also
find out more videos right here so if
you enjoyed this video if you find this
video to be useful just give it a thumbs
up share it and subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more healthy recipes
and also workout videos all the best